the left often controls language so this
is a Christian instead of calling her
anti-l LBGTQ why don't you call her
pro-traditional family why don't you
call her Pro she's religious she doesn't
believe in same-sex marriage that's not
a reason to she's not anti she's
pro-something so when we do that
anti-immigrant why because you want to
secure border so I just I encourage
people to always just not fall into that
trap now I don't know the specificity of
her policy on this that but just be
cautionary about being these labels that
they throw out there you know it's the
same as all racist bigot anti you know
they throw these labels out when they
want to just have somebody look like a
bigot instead you know she has her own
set of values she has her own set of
things she believes in she's really
they're people religious all over the
United States by the way who don't
believe in same-sex marriage not because
they hate gay people but because they're
religious and that's they're looking at
the Bible they're not bigots so just be
careful with accepting the language of
the left because it's meant to
stigmatize